grazie president schäuble salute or
present teeth or the aunt the
visitators presence the president the
president learn a lot this
ok president concilio designated
boss michael salute commissioner karin
president the the signals from the leyen
in chamonix president the the group political slogan
i was 17 years  old
a young
person who is allowed to experience a lot of new things every day
i know the tears in the eyes of my
parents my acquaintances my friends
seen but the pictures in the
tv
programs was first of all about the questions at the time and then about the
fall of the
wall i felt  we felt that here
experiencing history
it was wonderful that the first
compatriots arrived at my home in
lower bavaria with the so-called
trabis and we intuitively felt that
what belongs together comes together
as a german i was deeply impressed
when i saw the people in leipzig
dresden  and east berlin on the streets
g  ingen
for your courage for your desire for
unity in freedom for a citizen
i am deeply grateful to you
you created values ​​that shape us to this day
the citizens are
the heroes of unity your voice was
heard because strong allies did
not let you down
one  my first
key political experience was when
ronald reagan stood in front of the brandenburg gate two years before the fall of the
iron curtain
and gorbachev demanded
that the wall be torn down the european
community nato all its
members always agreed on one point
the division of europe must be overcome
support the americans  and what the europeans gave the
germans 30 years
ago was a real
gift
after two
destructive world wars this leap of faith was anything but
a matter of course
our
allies should always think of this trust, even though
we in germany sometimes
feel fragmented and critical  table discussing the future of europe
the friends of germany
didn't paint failure on the wall
they saw the future they
trusted in many areas they were
real statesmen and women
about wolfgang schäuble how you
negotiated the german unity
treaty was historic and, more importantly,
successful for you
my political generation
owes a great deal to theo
waigel and helmut kohl even back then there were a lot of
concerns i read them in the newspapers i heard them at the university in the shop when i was
shopping not everyone was enthusiastic
about the developments back then but they
didn’t take any notice of them  impress you
also shown in leadership your actions your
far-sightedness was formative
thank you for that and we can need this leadership
today
no one doubts anymore today the german
and the european unity are
inseparable
what does his german patriot
stand for but he never left any doubt about a
united one  democratic  s europe is our
common mission in the europe project
he was committed to the last course in the truest sense of the word
because i was
a fervent european because i was a
great statesman everyone saw helmut kohl at
the end of his career
when we said goodbye to him in the
strasbourg plenary hall
the father of german unity said
goodbye in the european
parliament
helmut kohl knew the fall of the wall
was not a singular national event
yes i can't do a national
feat either will germans owe the
unity in freedom to the courage of thousands of
friends in eastern europe including politicians like
lech walesa basler varel  josef share
not only fights for the freedom of
his own country but for the whole of europe
and we should uphold the spirit of the
peaceful revolution the spirit of the
peaceful awakening in our
generation
too today a lot of small things dominate
everyday political life, but especially today
we are paper before big ones
challenge  faced with challenges and
we can learn from the fall of the wall we can
only achieve something great if we
stand together in europe
europe is the key
to a better future that is worth living in
and for that it is necessary
to work on European awareness today i love
my homeland bavaria
i am  I don't like being German I'm
a European at heart we mustn't
allow nationalists populists
to destroy this unity of identities
I like being European let's renew
European cohesion today as we
lived it 30 years ago
thank you
President of the bdp region politically
realistic democratic character
pass the  senior in the restaurant in
front of the moment or illusion be
illusion esperanza new yorker janácek station
wagons how the lossburg bring southeast asia
what they do
lasko last.fm djs constant the levy
author from bonn and explosion of the cases
lots of us dollars again constant
versiko.de customer moderator  solution  ns
maxiscoot from the austria team
invest
jjs after this comment
the patients let the al qaida
the modern berlin super shoulder
young birds as a demographic as a liberal
andré blockus as well as adecco in hude and
papa the esperanza lucky loser topspins
amos kenan portrait africa pension the
loose rachel schumann  let go i
love the list of the region in the costume
of the man just mania bulgaria slovakia
and recites and that's not the
paradise model and the democracy
parliamentarians on the pension at the
trend on your airbus must be separately everything
utopia of the engine sony dialog goes
international happened  it that
the tory is already very surprised that everything in the vaults of the ubs
or classic in jerseys the
treibacher doris upor stb nl abdullah
demography scenario in the bonaparte of the world cup
and eastern europe as a populist the bank account of
the renault 4 hours sabrina profound
reflection britta bolte scooters the
restoring
whole story apparatus  [ __ ] the
l  ibertas trend accessory many
national man is limitless and even
better when exploring is available
around with christsozialen in minsk at
alemannia cabaret analog motor or whether
he consequences of la comunidad you
come super concentrated the music and
the interview is rosalia shower or
porsche logo ok-  president of the bagno
felipe gonzález cano du in june was
the coalition with the success
schiele or astra model
libertas came to you as a customer from
malaysia ramos has to train and
models massa interested in the salute he
is as much as kristina barrois
[music]
left the hobby in  cooperation
with bajaj come self-constructed with group
yes politician is sabina could
importante of the family social democrats
esther parliament
at the moment there then importante
paternostro politicians laughed and
photography us president
[music]
communists
european headquarters the lawn square radio europe democracy
democracy politics he sees positively
japan threaten europe  dear  ration front your
reaction or container format of the
provocative matter of migration all
europeans is the the parasitologist bosses
continent only extreme europe
buried once stream point of the tour de ski
barrier in the buses of the thermal baths in cala
libertad political prosperity party
thale political schily of good
offices authoritarians  europe democracy
the council of europe djk the nikko asset arena
profits the benefit chile appenzeller
union europe career was lost
ideal was jessica fox disney
berta demokratia prosperity bag union
europe only l and
patrice chéreau conference europe of the professional duo pressure
coming karissa implies that junior
open falls at drogba  basel only
projects or pankow annika wort if
at ducati body conception before the
european energy award of different de
golem are machos logo city rules
extreme local boss 4s shooting met with
chester sinsheim and projects or palestine
president
[applause]
active generation
the  divided york got places baby blue
magic pity the manager
the manager looking for freedom riders
nor djerba counter the does not forget
was look for freedom to know that
andante gates
without the great escape of purchasing
manager s
the post horn rotten down 1 on
november is at night  days to remind you be
courage to take that divides and change
the world presidents identified for the group
ballaballa dear
president dear
sir dr
schäuble ladies and gentlemen 30 years ago in
one of the happiest hours of
german history the wall fell
our compatriots  in the former gdr
against a totalitarian and brutal
system on the streets they demonstrated
they risked their health even their
lives this heroic and consistently
peaceful operation finally brought
the wall down and an
unjust socialist regime to the
implosion
so far so gratifying so really so
beautiful  n but what was supposedly swept away with the
peaceful revolution
is back
today socialism and communism
were not finally defeated as hoped
it is alive it is right in front of all our
eyes on a deeper level again
today even the sed successors are celebrating
german unity  With just like the
socialist greens and the
social democrats, they
all
wanted to prevent German
reunification at the time. Berlin itself is now governed by a deeply
red senate
that is striving for expropriation and destroying the price
mechanism and preparing exactly that.
The socialists and communists sit in
the German parliament
and you  smile unashamedly at
the plenary of the european
parliament where you destroy your freedom
agenda day by day implement
planned economy city market economy
correctly has dictates city true
freedom of speech is the lesson of
history still not learned every
every a  rt of socialism always
and without exception brings poverty impoverishment
bad injustice and violence
all this is unfortunately still undefeated
one last if you look at the ceremonies of these
days like this then you could think that the
people were celebrating the european
union today and not the attainment of
german unity
the peaceful ones  revolutionaries from 89
didn't chant eu united
fatherland but they called germany
united fatherland
they fought for freedom for identity
for democracy and year for national
sovereignty of germany
they didn't fight to fight not for
socialism through the back door they
also didn't fight for the european
union
meanwhile  work here on
overcoming the national
states in favor of an identity read nothing called united states of europe
you will see sooner or later
the freedom-loving citizens of europe
will also bring this absurd tower of
babel to collapse because that's what
d  he people 89 didn't take to the
streets and risked their heads and
necks if we don't return to a
europe of sovereign
fatherlands in which nations
exist peacefully and
cooperate sensibly with each other, the eu
as a whole will one day implode and
the brh exit just one  must have been the first beginning of
this implosion
do not underestimate the will to
freedom that is european
whoever sins against it will not have lasting
success thank you very much
[applause]
[music]
the lines already the apparatchiks the
party comrade became the story european
super duper european has come the
chimney is the system of politics
progress
infected dominant position
[music]
[applause]
president of the bwe group alain berger thank you very
much mr president unfortunately
one has to say about the current status of the debate
that not all  speakers have
done justice to the great task
but would like to
thank those who have expressed themselves in a differentiated way
it is as if someone has thrown open the
window after all the years of
stagnation in intellectual,
economic and political terms, as
stefan heym said at the big demonstration
on berlin's alexanderplatz on
4th november 1989, when the wall that fell
five days later collapsed  also piece
by piece the iron questions that separated east
and west europe economically,
militarily and last but not least
ideologically and it
is the merit of the
east germans who demonstrated for months for
democracy and freedom rights
that we can have this debate here today 30
years later in the european parliament
thank you very much mr president i was born in
east berlin experienced the wall as a
child and that also gives
me the opportunity to tell a more
differentiated story than the
two previous speakers
the vast majority of east germans is
according to the current  report by the german
federal government on the status of german
unity and satisfied with how
german unity and the post-reunification period went
the disc you
pointed out and why i would like to give you
an example ladies and gentlemen east germans
today still have to
work more hours a week and
at the same time, they earn less than their
west german colleagues,
east germany naturally has
the largest
low-wage sector in the entire
european union in terms of national values, i.e.
30 years after the political
turnaround, we need a social turnaround
not only for Germany but for
the entire european union
but it  is not only the social and
economic development that
still draws borders that should have
long since disappeared, these
are also the mistakes in dealings
between east and west if you don't just talk about east german and west germany, but
also
between east and  western europe have
been made in recent years and
i will give you another example
that
the writer
stefan heym i quoted he comes from a jewish
german family flees as an
antifascist body nazis to the
united states arrives as a soldier in
the us army back to
germany  to liberate germany from
national socialism
1952 he is a us citizen he decides
to do so and he is already an
internationally recognized writer to
settle in gdr
1994 a few years later so
after the fall of the wall he is listed as a
non-party member on the list of my party
in  elected to the federal parliament and will be the
senior president there and unfortunately my dear
colleagues, the conservative faction will leave
the hall as a whole when he is elected
mr schäuble you will remember that
i think that is a big
historical mistake
i think it was a culture break and
these are the stories  v  of victories and
defeats these are life
stories that must be told and heard today
, also in order to stop the attempts of the extreme
right to appropriate the history of
german unity the history of the
fall of the wall the history of
european unification
as it unfortunately has to experience again today
people and hungary poles
of czechoslovakia and last but not
least in the gdr wanted a future
in an open, peaceful,
free europe they, on the other hand,
stand for a europe of the past
of nationalism and new walls and
who today wants to build walls again at the
outer borders of the european union
operates a policy
that leads to people
fleeing their lives instead of finding help who
has understood absolutely nothing about the
fall of the wall and European unification
many thanks to
grazioli as cola co sees
spokeswoman rachel post without a colleague slipping
berlin's kosanovi  c in the face
story new delhi camera story mode
fukushima dostojewski unia lawyer was
a modern democracy legitimate
markus huster and vice peter
ramsauer only with a commission vice president of
the franz teams shaper mr
president dear ladies and gentlemen
when i was born it would have been a daring
dream  been that we once decided in a
european parliament with deputies
from east and west about our common
future
in the year i was born the wall was
built, which for me as for many
europeans is closely linked to my personal
history
when i was a young soldier
the cold war was raging  so hurriedly that i was
trained to fight against those
with whom i am now united in a union
in the year the wall
fell our son marc was born and when
europe finally became one again with the eastern enlargement in 2004
our son
max was born
our children  do a whole
generation of young people have the privilege
europ  knowing a exclusively as a continent
of peace, freedom and
unity
and we also owe that to the
peaceful revolution of
1989. for me and for everyone who was lucky
enough to experience
it, it is the most formative political event of our lives. it
is also the victory of european values
because i people's longing for
freedom was greater than fear, their
desire for democracy stronger than ideology and their cohesion more powerful than the regimes in eastern germany's central and eastern
europe it was the civil courage of
these people that rewrote the history of
our continent
and was their civil courage  truly
european the spark of freedom
was also kindled in the neighbors
at the time at the polish solidarnosc as well
as at the pan-european picnic on the
hungarian-austrian border around
the baltic way
what belongs together grows together as willy brandt
said and he didn’t just mean
germany  special  ern all of europe we
owe this to europe could also the
courageous actions of neighbors and
partners who opened up to a reunited
germany in the heart of the continent
that was not a matter of course at the time
that was not only a courageous step for us president
george bush and ex soviet president michail gorbachev
but was  especially important for
france and great britain it
meant embedding germany in
europe and venturing into a completely
new dimension of
europe a europe that reunites its two halves
that unites western, central and eastern europe into a
single continent, that’s exactly
what we’ve had in the past  30 years ago
i still remember
well that before the fall of the wall i was able to
feel and see whether i was in the west
or the east and that was not just
because of the special scent of trabis and gdr
cigarettes
when i am now
in the east or west with my children
I'm on the road in Europe,
there are e.g  there were still cultural
differences because diversity is because
diversity is europe's wealth
but you can't look at people
where they come from they are interested in the
same topics and have the
same worries and hopes and
dreams there is no longer the old and
the new europe in the traditional sense
it's also not that the east joined the
west no we
grew together to form our europe
one of the greatest successes after the fall
of the iron curtain was it delivers a
fable it aptly described the
east and west no longer as moral
but as purely geographical
designations have become the
foundation of our europe forms form
democracy freedom and human rights
in europe the
rule of law must govern
this was and will remain the main mandate main
mandate of the peaceful revolution
in 1989 freedom and equal
rights for all
unity and justice and freedom
i would say it is for all of us
responsibility to respect and defend these values
they are they are the product of
europe only in this way could it
become a continental success in solidarity for a goal grandpa
our successful internal market creates
jobs guaranteed access to
education and health insurance and
creates opportunities for every single case
everyone  conjuring up the so-called national
interest of nostalgia or westalgia or other unprecedented pasts in
order to play east and west in
germany and europe off against each other
, we must therefore
resolutely
oppose there are still challenges in growing
together we are all aware of that
, but the fact that the eu
the best thing is what could have happened to east and west
we must be clear whoever
plays with europe is gambling away the future
and whoever really wants to trade in the interests of their
country relies on europe
only together can we hold our weight
on the world stage  play out and
help shape the rules of the game
if we want to continue the task of the people
from 1989 today, then
we would also have to show European
courage and that also means courage for
Europe because we can only master the challenges of the
future, from climate change to the
digital revolution,
if we join forces
at the awarding of the nobel prize in
1971, willy brandt said that peace is not an
original state it rather has to be made again and
again by people
social justice is above all decisive for a lasting peace
because such fire material
need is concrete and freedom our common european task
this remains  overcoming working on it is
europe's destiny dear wolfgang
schäuble thank you very much for showing us
what we are fighting for and dear sir
thank you for showing us
we are fighting
[applause]
[music]
ladies and gentlemen
despite this great change the
30  years ago through the courageous and
resolute action of the peoples on
what was then the east side of the iron
curtain we face challenges in
europe some of the achievements in
the european union are perhaps
too self-evident worldwide experiencing
the tendencies of new countries to build it
out to slay them
we see  the signs of
proper international
cooperation being called into question
in such a turbulent and
turbulent period it is good
to get back to
basics and remember the fundamental values
that also led to a great change 30 years ago
so i am proud of it  saying here in
your best parliament that
democracy, the rule of law and
fundamental rights must always be
defended because they are the cornerstones
of european
june and it made it very
clear to state that authoritarianism,
totalitarianism or nationalism is never
ours  re answer our choice
should always be freedom
our choice should always be the party
and our choice should always be the people
mr schäuble said to himself that we
share the same values ​​that's true
not just us but the whole world of
this world of words the  are the
values ​​of the whole world recognized by the
united nations
ladies and gentlemen now
what belongs together is growing together
when the berlin wall fell these were
the wise words of the former
federal chancellor of the
federal republic of germany willy
brandt who was at the level of the mayor of
western  berlin was and also
saw the division of europeans in a very concrete way
i am firmly convinced
that the message of unity is the
key to the success of the
european union we can only be
strong together and we need
a europe that is t1 and not a europe
that is  separates the promise of
united europe thank you very much for your
au  attention
grazie migration does the night offers
tibco loro piana has already been interviewed
here in graz motivated collaborations
in graz school
president federal parliament president schäuble des tory the amour
lalalala music
[music]
[applause]